Jumanji: Welcome to the Jungle turned out
far better than anyone had any right to expect.
What initially sounded soulless and cynical
ended up being a massively successful, well-received,
family-friendly thrill ride for kids and adults
alike.
Starring Dwayne Johnson, Kevin Hart, Jack
Black, and Karen Gillan, the movie effectively
built on the 1995 story about a magical board
game with a video-game-based, body-swap comedy
sequel.
Welcome to the Jungle made a lot out of a
wacky premise, but that doesn't mean it was
perfect.
Many of its quirks won't be picked up by younger
viewers, but the adults in the room probably
noticed them.
Here are some of the things only grown-ups
will notice in Jumanji: Welcome to the Jungle.
What console is that?
Jumanji opens in 1996, introducing viewers
to a teenage boy named Alex in a sleeveless
Metallica tee whose bedroom is covered in
pop culture posters from the era.
Nothing says "1996 teenager" like his quick
dismissal of the Jumanji board game in favor
of his trusty PlayStation controller.
We see he's playing Twisted Metal, a game
that was released for the Playstation in November
1995.
But when we pause to marvel at the all the
authentic 90s stuff in his room, we get a
good look at the console itself.
Spoiler alert: that's no PlayStation.
It doesn't even remotely resemble a PlayStation.
From the looks of things, its closest twin
is the Atari 2600, a wood-paneled console
that was already 20 years old in the mid-90s.
And of course, since you've noticed it once,
you're not going to be able to ignore that
the controllers go from PlayStation to vaguely
Nintendo-esque when the kids pull the game
out at the school.
Fittingly enough, they can't make heads or
tails of this odd contraption either.
"What is it, some kind of old-school Nintendo
or something?"
"I don't think so.
I don't recognize it."
Have your cheesecake
It seems to be a common belief that just acknowledging
overdone clichéd tropes is enough to subvert
them in movies or shows, but that's not really
always the case.
Jumanji uses Martha as a mouthpiece to criticize
the unnecessarily skimpy outfit worn by her
avatar, Ruby Roundhouse.
But, as good a sentiment as this might be,
the film is making this commentary on how
women are designed in video games while it
simultaneously benefits from having a young
actress in a skimpy outfit.
Fortunately, the movie is brimming with charm,
and doesn't rely too heavily on sexy shots
of a woman's body to keep people watching.
In fact, she adds bits of her male companions'
outfits to her own in order to feel a bit
more comfortable as she journeys through the
jungle kicking bad guy butt with her dance
fighting techniques.
But the marketing for the movie has no such
subtlety, making this a noticeable instance
of Jumanji wanting to have its cake and eat
it too.
"Parrish" the thought
At the midpoint in the film, when the teens
have been set upon by corrupt researcher Russel
Van Pelt and there's no obvious way to move
forward, the missing teenager Alex shows up
in the avatar of Jefferson "Seaplane" McDonough.
He leads our heroes through a hallway full
of authentically video gamey traps to his
little hideaway set apart from the main Jumanji
playing area.
He's been holed up there for who knows how
long, keeping his head down and trying to
hold onto his last life.
He explains to the new kids that the little
bungalow where he lives, drinking delicious
margaritas, is not a structure of his own
making.
Instead, it once belonged to a man named Alan
Parrish.
Alan Parrish is, of course, Robin Williams'
character from the original Jumanji.
Not only is the reference a lovely tip of
the hat to Alan's character, it also gives
fans of the original movie a glimpse at how
Alan was living during his years away.
Alex's amazing slang
"She's pretty fly."
"She da bomb."
"I'm just saying.
I'm sure they'd like to get jiggy with her."
Alex's tortured 90s slang is out of place
in the jungle, and also this century.
But his lame-o vocabulary helps the four kids
realize that the Alex they've found inside
the game is Alex Vreeke, the boy who's been
missing, and stuck in Jumanji, for 20 years.
It's not a bad idea to use outdated slang
to tip off the characters that Alex is from
another era, but there are a few problems
here.
One is that Will Smith's "Gettin' Jiggy Wit
It" came out in 1997, not 1996.
Plus, exactly zero people have ever actually
used the phrase "gettin' jiggy" in conversation.
Ever.
Ask your parents.
Also, if they were going to go there with
that style of slang, they probably should
have gone with a different characterization
for Alex.
Instead of a Metallica tee and a grungy hairstyle,
he probably should have been wearing a Cross
Colours tank top and some radical prints.
The walls of his bedroom should have been
covered in TLC and Michael Jordan posters.
Now that's 90s.
Instead, his lingo comes off as forced.
Everyone knows mid-90s metalheads didn't say
anything was "da bomb!"
Then again… no one really knows what they
say sometimes.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
The empty Fridge
While Kevin Hart does good work as Fridge's
avatar, Fridge himself has no real arc, and
learns no valuable life lessons in the movie.
Things start off promising.
We learn that Fridge asked Spencer to do his
homework as a favor, which turns out to be
a bad idea.
Spencer may be a nerd, but he's not necessarily
a good student, and the bogus paper he provides
for Fridge is easily sniffed out by his teacher.
As a result, Fridge gets kicked off of the
football team.
Later, when Fridge and Spencer's tension comes
to a head on a cliff in Jumanji, they get
into a shoving match, costing Spencer one
of his lives.
But by working together through the rest of
the adventure, they gain a mutual respect
for one another.
Still, at the end of the movie, the problems
that led to that cliff confrontation are still
there.
The boys haven't hashed out their personal
conflict.
Fridge doesn't apologize for using Spencer
to do his homework, nor for insulting and
intimidating him in Jumanji.
They don't team up in the real world to get
Fridge reinstated to the football team.
There's no shot of Fridge working hard on
his own homework, or doing anything to wrap
up the problems that got him in detention
in the first place.
All that's changed about him at the end of
his bogus journey with Spencer, Bethany, and
Martha is that he seems nicer and vaguely
content.
The movie doesn't want you to notice it, but
his academic and athletic future is still
severely compromised by the movie's end.
Compare him to the other characters: Bethany
finally begins to take an interest in the
world outside herself.
Spencer gets the nerve to take a chance and
kiss Martha, and Martha gets over her shy
nervousness enough to kiss him back.
Fridge just spent all afternoon playing video
games — but all of his problems are still
there.
That's kind of how real life works, too.
The Alex paradox
Jumanji is a family movie, so a happy ending
is pretty much par for the course.
But let's put on our thinking caps for a second:
the implications of Alex returning to the
moment of his disappearance after being trapped
inside the game for 20 years should probably
be more severe than the movie lets on.
No, seriously, let's talk about this!
If a butterfly flapping its wings in one location
can have a dramatic ripple effect on everything
else in the world, then a human teenager going
missing would fundamentally change the fabric
of at least Brantford, New Hampshire.
Alex's unexplained disappearance from this
small town was a major cultural touchstone
for everyone who lived there.
It's mentioned multiple times by different
characters at the start of the film, and it's
the sort of event that would have all kinds
of small effects on people's' relationships
and behavior.
Parents probably have his disappearance in
the back of their minds while they're raising
their kids.
Old Man Vreeke, who was once vigorous and
full of life, has his destiny dramatically
changed by the anguish from mysteriously losing
his son.
The disappearance leads other people in town
to be more cautious over the years that follow.
The ending should have been more like Back
to the Future, with the tiniest changes in
the past having major effects in the years
that followed.
But nope!
That never happened.
Even after the timeline where Spencer, Fridge,
Martha, and Bethany were living in gets winked
out of existence and replaced by this new
world where Alex never went missing, everything
outside of Alex's family ends up being exactly
the same.
Beyond the confines of his household, it appears
that Alex's absence from the world meant just
about nothing.
That's insane!
Right?!
"At no point in your rambling, incoherent
response, were you even close to anything
that could be considered a rational thought."
Look, okay, fine, sure.
We realize this is a movie about a magical
video game, but that still just doesn't make
a whole lot of sense.
Okay?
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!